[Música]
pasamos ahora a hablar del día de hoy
que se conmemora el día internacional
contra la islamofobia pero también se
cumplen seis meses desde la muerte de la
joven masa mini de 22 años que fue
capturada y violentada por la policía de
la moral bajo el argumento de un mal uso
del velo islámico su fallecimiento causó
protestas masivas miles de detenciones y
más de 500 fallecidos vamos a conversar
sobre estos temas con imame quien es
invitado frecuente de France 24 y
presidente de la comunidad musulmana
amadía en Argentina Muchas gracias imán
una vez más por estar en directo a
América
Hola y con buen día pase con vos y
además es usual hablar con usted de
estos temas es el día contra la
islamofobia y fuera de los Países Árabes
es muy común la discriminación por
ejemplo contra las mujeres que usan el
velo esta prenda que usted sabrá muy
bien de que se ha convertido en un
símbolo opresor para las que buscan sus
derechos en países como Irán también es
una expresión cultural Pero también es
un imán de discriminación como
reconciliarnos o por ejemplo con el
sí como vos decís creo que para la mujer
es mucho más difícil especialmente las
musulmanas que viven en occidente porque
el velo ya les da una identidad y ya es
una visibilización para la gente
entonces Muchas veces ocurre que Una
musulmana Es agredida simplemente por el
hecho de usar el velo sea en un subte en
el transporte público en lugares incluso
hasta tal punto que algunas veces son
rechazadas o negadas la posibilidad de
trabajar en un lugar simplemente por el
hecho de usar el velo y ahí Creo que es
importante aclarar como musulmanes y
como representante de musulmana María en
Argentina rechazo totalmente Si hay
países en el occidente donde se impone o
obliga a la mujer quitarse el velo sí
como es algunas es el caso pero a su vez
el mismo de la misma manera condenó
También si hay países supuestamente
islámicos que imponen el velo a la mujer
no como usted
porque islam se basa sin raíz en la
libertad de religión en el ejercicio del
libre albedrío y La Única condición que
una mujer usa el velo es siempre y
solamente por su propia convicción y por
su propia erección porque el velo en
realidad es una una expresión universal
que encontramos en todas las religiones
no es algo único relacionado con el
islam por eso Incluso en el Corán se
menciona a la Virgen María quien también
usaba el velo como una expresión
simbólica de pudor de modestia y en ese
sentido también la mujer musulmana usa
el velo no es solamente para taparse la
cabeza o el pelo sino que es una
expresión simbólica de sus valores de su
pudor de su modestia sin embargo en
países como Irán que se declara una
República islámica lo que podríamos
decir según su explicación es que sea
deformado este significado no y ha sido
utilizado el velo además históricamente
como una medida de opresión contra las
mujeres que Que prácticamente
desaparecen de la vida pública porque es
que no les vemos más que los ojos
dependiendo del tipo de velo que
utilicen que se puede hacer en estos
casos es decir hay alguna salida para
para todas estas mujeres que padecen
bajo la obligatoriedad del velo
ahí Creo que es muy importante y Estoy
coincido totalmente con usted y hay que
plantear esa autocrítica hacia las
sociedades musulmanas y ahí realmente
traer otra o acudir a las enseñanzas
verdaderas del islam y planteárselas en
las mezquitas en las comunidades o
incluso en la mesa en la familia porque
el islam categóricamente prohíbe la
coacción en asuntos de fe prohíbe
categóricamente
usar la coacción para imponer
convicciones o preceptos religiosos en
nombre de Dios el islam categóricamente
defiende la libertad de religión el
islam enseña la separación del estado y
de la religión la religión debe siempre
ser una relación íntima personal de la
persona con el ser divino y en ese
sentido nosotros consideramos que
lamentablemente no solamente ahora con
el caso del velo sino que ahí también
otros casos donde Lamentablemente se
discrimina se viola las derechos los
derechos de la mujer en nombre del islam
Eso es lo más doloroso por ejemplo ahí
también ahora so donde la mujer ni
siquiera tiene el derecho de trabajar ir
a la universidad o participar en la vida
académica profesional Aunque el islam
enseña todo lo contrario ya en el siglo
siete el fundador del islam El Profeta
mohamedecer con él garantizó para la
mujer el derecho de votar de recibir
educación de casarse por su propio
consentimiento el derecho de divorcio el
derecho de heredar El derecho de manejar
la propiedad hasta tal punto que incluye
el profeta dijo que es la
responsabilidad o la obligación de Una
musulmana obtener educación desde la
cuna Hasta la tumba Pero por supuesto
Lamentablemente vemos en la práctica en
muchos países todo lo contrario Todo lo
opuesto y es una gran contradicción a
las enseñanzas verdaderas del islam por
eso es realmente muy necesario que la
sociedad musulmanas en vez de seguir
ciegamente al clérigo o lo que plantean
los religiosos acudir a las enseñanzas
verdaderas del seguir el islam a través
cómo lo vivió y practicó el fundador del
islam el profeta Mohamed la pasa con él
Claro pero esto se aleja completamente
de las versiones que encontramos por
ejemplo en Afganistán con el grupo
talibán por qué está tan arraigado en
nosotros los ciudadanos de occidente
este sentimiento de peligro ante el
islam que es ante todo como usted lo ha
venido diciendo una religión pacífica y
esto revisando nuestra historia desde
personajes como Sadam husein hasta el
estado islámico en sí mismo y Bueno aquí
occidente tiene no solamente pues eh
miedo sino también responsabilidad
totalmente Y creo que eso nos pasa a
todos los musulmanes especialmente que
vivimos en el occidente me ha tocado ese
también vivir en la propia carne a un
islam literalmente significa Paz hoy en
día Si hablas con la gente común tienen
una connotación negativa y eso era ella
realmente nos marcó el once de
septiembre un antes y un después Y
lamentablemente Hay que decir eso que
ahí minorías muy pequeñas adentro del
mundo musulmán encima son grupos
radicales extremistas tiene una agenda
geopolítica sí no son representantes de
la religión ni representan los valores
del islam pero lamentablemente han
manchado la imagen del islam hacen tanto
ruido que taparon o que tapan la mayoría
de los musulmanes y por eso creo que
también es necesario para el propio
mundo musulmán hay tomar una firmeza
tomar una postura firme condenar a ellos
separarse posicionarse y ahí en ese
sentido dejar bien claro sus posturas
preceptos sea ahora el caso de
otros casos también los grupos
terroristas que vivimos en diferentes
países asiáticos y en ese sentido para
nosotros como por ejemplo comemos
hermanas siempre es importante aclarar y
enseñar a la gente las enseñanzas
verdaderas del histano en Argentina por
ejemplo a lo largo del país hicimos en
los últimos meses varias campañas
experimentos sociales en las calles con
el cartel soy musulmán tenés alguna
pregunta entonces promovemos a la gente
alentamos a las personas que hablen
directamente con un musulmán Y en vez de
simplemente consumir la información a
través de las redes o los medios masivos
que se acerquen a los musulmanes que
hablen con ellos sobre su fe sus valores
Porque esos grupos como te dije en
resumen no representan los valores ni
las enseñanzas del islam y sin embargo
tristemente ya pareciera esta entrevista
hay que recordar lo que hace seis meses
falleció una joven de 22 años kurdo
iraní acusada de vestir mal el velo
Muchísimas gracias a usted imane marine
Will el presidente de la comunidad
musulmana en la amadia en Argentina que
tenga un feliz día
Gracias muchísimas gracias y que nos
esforcemos contra la discriminación
gracias a ustedes ya regresamos con más
en directo a América no se vayan
[Música]